uh steve weintraub with collider and i'm
thrilled to be here with the cast and
showrunner of tales of the walking dead
um first of all thank you so much for
coming in thank you thank you for having
us out here please i have uh let's just
say at least five questions but before
we get started uh terry knows that every
time i talk to him i bring up what's
known as the documentary known as
idiocracy yes
when did you realize that the film was
actually a documentary about our modern
times i got a call from time magazine
asking me all about the last election
and i was going why are you asking me
you know you're president camacho and i
went oh my goodness uh and then i knew
it it had really reached a fever pitch
of viral it was just super viral and
you know the movie gets bigger every
year um and
i don't know if that's a good thing you
know i mean i want it to be a funny and
like
i was talking on the comic-con panel
today that idiocracy has really turned
into a very true horror movie in a lot
of ways
that's how i knew he was perfect
that jenny got me yes so for people that
don't realize this is an anthology
series six episodes and i guess what do
you want fans to know about the series
do you have to have watched any of the
walking dead beforehand you do not there
is we have one recurring character and
in d meets alpha but um even that you
could probably tune in blind and
pick up where we are pretty quickly but
every other episode of standalone
maybe there's a little easter egg in a
couple of them that that hint to
something on the walking dead but i have
to ask you you said every other episode
is standalone yes so three of the
episodes are connected
no there's only one i just meant that in
here's a standalone
i just meant that stand alone in the
fact that they don't have anything to do
with the franchise or the world hers is
the only one that's really
very very connected
um but we might have a little easter egg
in there for you in a few of those
episodes sure so when i looked at the
footage it seemed like a lot of the epic
and again i don't 100 know but it seems
like a lot of the material takes place
at the beginning of everything is it
primarily are all the stories set at the
beginning of this event they're not we
set um
no they take place over uh
we
tentatively 35 years into the future
don't don't quote me on that scott will
kill me but um
um no we we wanted to go in
every direction of the united states
that we could go in and every timeline
that we could go in my episode was like
a thousand years in the future yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah they're speaking yeah
yeah they're robots actually um that's
not true that's not true sorry for the
cast i i love learning about like the
behind the scenes the making of a show
or a movie and and just hearing about
things that like a fan normally wouldn't
so for all three of you actually for all
four of you what do you think would
surprise people to learn about the
making of a walking dead show or
specifically this show
that's a good question um you know for
me
it was it was just the the amount of
work that goes into one episode people
would have no idea listen we are doing a
full feature film in 10 days
and i mean
everything uh and it's almost it's it's
almost like
i i don't remember stopping filming
you know it was like 10 days continuous
like i think i went to sleep but
or was i just
in the apocalypse you know what i mean
like it was it was hard to figure out
and you know it was another thing is is
that you know you didn't want it to be
easy because it is the apocalypse and by
the time i got done and you know there
were things that i was resisting like
you know snacks and different things
that little little creature comforts
because you wouldn't have that and so to
get in into character and to really do
this thing right it was a lot of
sacrifice that a lot of people would
would think oh yeah they're probably
drinking smoothies and having a good
time no it's it's one of those things
that you want to be in touch with the
whole time you're filming yeah i was
eating only like salads and unseasoned
foods
i swear
it just so happened that it aligned with
like a
men's health shoot that i was doing so i
was just like um eating really clean but
like
yeah it was just like but but it also
like added to the schedule shoot like it
made it feel so
um a lot tougher on just like you know
you're surviving and i think one of the
moments that i realized like and i guess
this is what you're asking is seeing a
family of walkers
in the green room on their phones
and so it was like a family just that
was just sitting down and um
they were just like texting and you know
waiting to be called on set and i
thought it was one of the funniest
things to just experience behind the
scenes
just to put it in context when we talk
about movies movies can take like let's
say an average low budget movie in the
uk would take between four and five
weeks okay to shoot a movie
and a hollywood movie they take months
and they have long lunches and they get
a lot of time to work everything out and
lighting works you hit the ground
running on this show the crew are like
insanely talented and it's not that it's
like dangerously tight it's it's the
time it's it's that for a reason and no
one messes about there's no like baggy
sides you know everything is just tight
and we get on with it and it's
yeah it's really good that's a great
point does it actually make again i
don't actually know listen i've been on
shoots where people are lucky to get two
takes and i've been on other things
where you know they are shooting until
they get it right so what is it like
when you're shooting something like this
do you have like it's basically three
takes every time or are you sometimes
one take you're moving on
from my experience it's different every
year sorry my experience is different
every episode it just depends on the
rhythm of the day and how much we need
to get done and
i love the helicopter it's fantastic
this is listen the pro of being outside
is no masks it's beautiful the backdrop
rhymes flying yeah yeah the negative
[Applause]
what people don't realize is terry has a
huge fan base that loves to take
paparazzi shots from helicopters
shout out to the navy so there have been
many drones that have ruined shots on
the walking dead that's fans driving
yeah yeah and so it's it's cheaper to
like reshoot it than to like paint it
out i it's just or it's also sounds yeah
that's right yeah oh so the amount of
takes do you typically is it like
sometimes
can you sort of talk about that it does
it really honestly depends on the actor
on the actor
and there's so many elements that go
into a shot as well especially if it's
kind of handheld and everything's
choreographed it can be one
you know supporting artist that misses
their queue and they're not in the show
or they're blocked you know there's so
so many elements that it's like magic
it's like a dance
you know we're going to get the dance
right they do a wonderful job because
again we're not talking about doing uh
you know feature length script you know
what i'm saying it's really we have
enough time to do what we need to do
but it's just so deep and it's so
exhausting because it's it and and
the way channing and these guys have set
this thing up is that there's certain
set pieces there's certain things that
are just more pivotal than others all
right we need to spend this time on this
scene you know what i mean and then
other things it's like okay we can get
that done yeah no totally like a
dialogue scene is is completely
different than when you're fighting a
walker exactly it's correct
so it was like they they know
how the pacing should go they know
they've been in this world they
understand it but also the thing is is
that it's like we're singing our version
of the walking dead song which could be
a total different tone a different pace
you know what i mean it's like i look at
i will always love you by dolly parton
is way different than the one by whitney
houston and you say and it's almost with
this anthology series i feel it's the
same way it's a different song every
time you see it and you're like wow i
didn't hear it like this but it's the
same words you know i mean it's like
that world does not change so for the
three of you can what can you say about
your particular episode i'm assuming all
three are in different episodes or no i
think the the really fun thing about
tackling this
is um
how different each episode is and the
genres they play with within one genre
there's a lot of
ways to approach
a zombie apocalypse and i think that
each of them having their own dna and
their own
fingerprint on how
because all of us like we we all live
life and but we all approach life so
differently and um i think within
different stories different stories like
cater to a different genre more so than
others and i think that was
what i think is one of the most exciting
things about this anthology series is
that it's six different
stories that have a little bit of a
different tone um
and yeah i don't know tell me a little
bit more about it about my episode oh um
well no i think that that that's where
that's i just laid out i made it broad
though so because so i wouldn't get in
trouble because i think i don't want to
yeah i don't want to
put it too you know yeah yeah
again you're doing it right anytime we
can plug the site it's great collider
right okay now yeah we're now we're you
know i'm not gonna pay you for this you
gotta you might as well just lighter
right
can you tease anything besides what i've
seen in the footage well i i can say
it's me and olivia munn and olivia uh we
have chemistry that goes way back from
the beginning you know we did newsroom
together
uh with aaron sorkin and name dropping i
see the way that oh no i love that jar
that's the name to drop you know what i
mean i heard that working on a sorkin
piece is
whoa it's a lot um
it it made us better because it was
brutal uh you you can't change a line
you can't do you have to say things the
way aaron wants you to say them
exactly in his cadence and the whole
thing and it was disciplined uh but by
doing that we developed this chemistry
that we revisited in this episode uh and
it was really to me
because i like to see comedy and horror
are two sides of the same coin
and i always love
the the release that comedy brings a
very tension filled moment and let me
tell you olivia handles that like a
champ like wow
and it's gonna be very refreshing to see
i think that the the touch of comedy in
our episode is one of the things that
makes it different
i think um
for those people out there who obviously
watch the show was the walking dead and
they know who you know alpha is i think
for me
when i read the episode there's such a
twist
that i didn't see coming that i think
that is that's like wow so well done i
mean insanely brilliant and um
i was like
i'm not used to this stuff
so that's that's
not a spoiler but it's like that yeah if
i felt like that and if you love the
show and you love alpha just
yeah how did you guys actually was it
the network that said we want six
episodes um because it seems like
recently and i could be wrong but a lot
of shows are moving to six and eight
episode seasons and i'm just curious if
that was a network we always knew it was
gonna be six episodes there was the
possibility at one point that it might
be eight but we knew going in that it
was six episodes however
my writer's room and i came up with i
think 25 different ideas for what those
six episodes could be so you know we got
a season two ready for now um but uh
it
we had to whittle it down from that many
ideas into the sex that we shot one of
the things about doing an anthology show
like this i think back on i don't know
if you guys remember the show quantum
leap but so i loved quantum leap and the
thing that most people didn't realize is
every episode was essentially a pilot
because they had to redo everything cast
all new cast all new locations it's
really hard to do an anthology show like
you guys are doing it's the same thing
every week as a pilot so what the hell
is that like putting it together and you
know the challenges that go with that
that was definitely a wake-up call
because i had been in the walking dead
world for so long i knew the crew was
amazing i knew we could i knew the
challenges that the walking dead itself
has um and then on so i was like we got
this but then on top of that to put in
new cast every episode new director's
new setting and also
we're shooting in one place but it's
supposed to be set all over america so
we had to make everything look as
different as we possibly could so that
was a that was the biggest challenge
that we we faced honestly though how
great to be challenged because otherwise
what's the point why do anything else
you know the walking dead it's done you
know it's sadly it's coming to an end
but that has been said
why why do it it's not it's it's not
that the network said we want this
they do but it's um it's because they're
original new ideas and they have a space
and they're relevant and important
it's exciting oh there
was the we go
the mic drop is perfect on that note um
i'm gonna wrap with you guys who can do
so you guys can do more speed dating
with other people and i'm just gonna say
i'm really looking forward to seeing the
series thank you so much for coming by
and for people that don't realize what's
the day it premieres in august august
14th 14th 5pm right exactly i didn't i
didn't remember that amc and amc plus
yes yeah amc plus it's two episodes
right i think so yeah yeah sneak peek
and i even think that you get the next
week's episode early if you're a
subscriber you like the way i did that
very very happy yeah
but seriously thank you guys so much
you